this video is brought to you by morning
brew
hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
just when you think you have a solid
understanding of the modern
technological landscape
it throws you a curveball seemingly
overnight
the term nft has managed to infiltrate
every corner of the web and it's all
about crypto collectibles
non-fungible tokens or nfts are
exploding in popularity
they're being used by things like art
baseball cards and even
jack dorsey's first tweet powered by
blockchain technology
everything from digital trading cards
video game items
art music and tweets are being bought
and sold on online trading auctions
one's ownership of these items is being
represented by nfts
in this video we'll go over some insane
things that are going on in the nft
space
and then move on to some sensible uses
and finally
finish off with what i find most
exciting about the space
so let's take a look you are watching
cold fusion tv
so what are nfts nft stands for
non-fungible token
the word fungible means that one item
can be replaced by another item
it's usually used in the context of
economics
for example you wouldn't care if i gave
you two five dollar bills instead of one
ten dollar bill
all dollars are the same likewise all
bitcoins are the same
you also wouldn't care which exact
bitcoin you receive
you're just interested in its value the
complete opposite of this
is something that is non-fungible and
this is where nfts come in
they're essentially a digital
certificate of authenticity that cannot
be replicated
nfts are stored in a blockchain and are
used to represent ownership of unique
items
thanks to the secure nature of
blockchain technology the record of
ownership is always available
it cannot be modified and it also
ensures that there can only be one owner
at a given time
while there are various emerging
blockchains implementing their own token
system
the ethereum blockchain is the most
commonly used for nft creation and use
although you may just be hearing about
nfts now the idea of a token system
running on crypto blockchains has been
experimented with for almost a decade
now the earliest example of crypto based
tokens was coloured coins
it was introduced by yona assi in 2012
and ran on the bitcoin blockchain
these tokens were small denominations of
bitcoin that are similar to current nfts
and they were intended for use as
certificates of ownership
unfortunately colored coins were flawed
due to the bitcoin system simply not
being set up to support it
and thus it was abandoned despite this
the crypto community began recognizing
the potential for assets stored on a
blockchain
in 2014 a peer-to-peer financial
platform called counterparty was
launched
it was built on top of the bitcoin
blockchain but with many improvements
and it laid the foundations for modern
nfts
in no time at all the idea of
blockchain-powered tokens began
expanding
into strange territories
in 2016 a meme trading community arose
it was called rare pepes and launched on
the counterparty platform
this used counterparty's tokenized asset
system to facilitate the trading of pepe
the frog memes
thanks to this movement there was
suddenly a working crypto token market
for digital art
by 2017 there was a major shift from
bitcoin-based token platforms like
counterparty
to the newly successful ethereum
blockchain unlike bitcoin
ethereum had a system for token creation
and storage
built right into its blockchain it was
ethereum that coined the term
non-fungible token this meant that
third-party platforms like counterparty
were no longer necessary
so ethereum took what had been attempted
over the past five years
perfected it and became a market leader
in blockchain asset tokens
more and more collectible digital assets
started appearing to make use of
ethereum's nfts
crypto punks created by matt hall and
john watkinson was digital pixel art
that became quite popular
ten thousand unique characters were
created and offered for free to ethereum
users
they quickly snatched them all up and
the thriving market was born
and fun fact last month one of these
crypto punks sold for 1.6
million dollars just a quick update
while i was editing
another crypto punk just sold for over 7
million dollars
so why pay so much for a jpeg file
at a high level you can think of it like
buying a one-of-a-kind original print of
a painting signed by an artist
although anyone can download and copy a
cryptopunk a million times
no one else will have that original if
you think it's a pretty weak idea for a
business case
i do too but we'll talk about all of
this and discuss it later in the episode
continuing on with our nft journey it
wasn't until october of 2017
that nfts broke out from the crypto
community
the story of one particular digital
asset became
infamous it generated reactions spanning
from utter confusion
to outrage it was cryptokitties
cryptokitties was a digital trading game
launched by the vancouver-based company
axiom zen it exploded with popularity
cnbc claimed that it was quote
epitomizing the cryptocurrency mania the
trading popularity of cryptokitties
was unmatched by similar nft assets look
like
the genes in their code define their
physical appearance
on 12 features based on a template by a
human designer
they call those features cattributes
like us these cats can also carry traits
in their code that only show up
in their offspring and although the hype
did die down over a few short months
a community was established and still
perseveres till today
it has become clear that rare pepe
crypto punks and cryptokitties
were just the beginning for nfts and in
the years since
the digital asset industry has expanded
beyond belief
over the next couple of years nfts
representing gifts
images videos music albums and much more
were eventually being sold
one of the most recent success stories
to gain media attention was the website
nba top shot off the back of the
cryptokitty success
axiom zen now called dapper labs has
spent the past three years working on
the nba plays trading platform
think of it as basketball cards but
instead of owning an image of lebron
james on the card
you can own the video of a specific
moment in a specific game
this ownership has nothing to do with
the licensing and in addition
the video can be seen by others much
like the other nfts we mentioned earlier
the ownership is solely on the
blockchain
as strange as it all sounds people are
still willing to pay big bucks
they do this because they think that
someone else in the future will pay even
more than they did at a later date
in under a year the beta version of the
site has seen 200 million dollars pass
through in direct sales a clip of lebron
james dunking has sold for over two
hundred thousand dollars
the community clearly sees value here
but if i'm 100 honest
i don't really see it but moving away
from collectibles
the content creation industry has also
embraced the possibilities of nfts
struggling artists and musicians can
leverage nfts as a powerful tool
the band kings of leon surprised fans
with a collection of nfts available for
sale
from unique artwork to images of golden
ticket passes for upcoming shows
the band also became the first to
release an album on nft
this next segment of nft news is brought
to you by morning brew digital artist
people whose real name is mike winkleman
recently sold an nft 10 second video
for 6.6 million dollars noah davis who
is familiar with the sale explains that
it's a sign of
quote a drastic shift a demographic
shift and a generational shift
that needs to be capitalized on i
personally think that people is very
talented and a bit of a cultural icon in
the digital age
so maybe this one isn't as crazy as the
next examples you're about to see
if you want more news stories like this
and love science technology and business
morning brew is for you it's a news
aggregator that sends you a daily
wrap-up of high quality news sources
it's sent to your email inbox each
weekday and saturday without you having
to lift a finger and best of all
it's free and just takes five seconds to
sign up to get started
just click the link below
so far we've learned that nfts are a way
of claiming unique ownership over
digital works
but very recently things have started to
get crazy
we all know that high-end art being sold
for exorbitant prices is nothing new
but some nft stories of insane
valuations are getting increasingly
harder to justify
a virtual plot of land in the video game
decentraland
recently sold for 80 000
taco bell has got in on the action and
they sold a gif
for twenty thousand dollars and i think
the award for the most ridiculous
nft goes to crypto trucks this is a
drawing that my friend showed me
yes this truck that you're seeing on
your screen that looks like it's been
drawn by a five-year-old
sold for over three hundred thousand
dollars kudos to the guy who managed to
sell it
and condolences to the person who bought
it
not to be outdone twitter ceo jack
dorsey
has put his first ever tweet on auction
the current highest bid
2.5 million dollars and again you can go
to twitter and look at this tweet
yourself
for free to me it looks a bit like 1999.
at the time stocks were at an all-time
high beanie baby prices were
skyrocketing and people wanted to get
rich quick
there's echoes of all of that today but
this time there's a lot more money in
the system
from house prices to high-end cars and
art asset prices are booming and it's
kind of starting to look like a bubble
getting ready to burst
i could be wrong though collector
communities can endure in a secondary
market
long after the initial hype has faded
so this is how i think things will go
the nft bubble will grow bigger and then
pop
after this nfts will get a bad
reputation when all the hype fades
but then after this the real world uses
will start arising
just like google and amazon rose from
the ashes of the dot-com bust when many
others didn't survive
nfts will start having wide appeal in
applications that have real world
utility
here are a few examples of what i expect
to be more sustainable uses for nfts
purchasing domain names collateral in
decentralized crypto loans
the registration of a car or a deed to a
home
these are all uses that the average
person can understand and take part in
but the most exciting use of nfts for me
is the concept of membership
for example i could release a cold
fusion nft that grants you
the viewer voting rights and what videos
come next and other perks such as merge
and future releases of music from me the
cold fusion token would also double as
an investment in the channel
almost like shares in a company here's
what i mean
say if i only make 100 of these tokens
if the channel grows and is perceived to
be more valuable
you the viewer could sell this token to
someone else for a profit
this concept logically makes sense to me
it gives buyers of the cold fusion nft
immediate value but also a way of
profiting if they hold on to it and
resell it
buying something like a crypto truck
makes less sense to me
with the news stories focusing on the
outrageous side of this technology
it's easy to see nfts as a hyped craze
waiting to die out
but as i just described i think there's
actually more to it
nfts are already primed for widespread
applications
in both outrageous and mundane ways
while we may be distracted by nba
players and crypto trucks
nfts may quietly become a part of all of
our lives without us
ever noticing
in the next episode we'll take an
interesting look at the origins of
bitcoin from the 1980s onwards
and then later we'll take a look at how
far it's come and explore who bitcoin's
creator might be
is part one of a two-part series so make
sure you're subscribed so you can catch
it
so thanks for watching my name is tagogo
and you've been watching cold fusion and
i'll catch you again soon for the next
episode
cheers guys have a good one
cold fusion it's new thinking